[Music]  that's not a knife that's a knife that's  me  Brian Dundee really yeah really  how do you keep saying really draw their  might nothing to see here man just get  the clean shane with my my [ __ ] - Barry  you know when you dad did it he was he  was mocking and well my dad told me  about this he was just like yeah I just  came up and you did this okay I just  don't think you can see you from back  here not a lot of Crocs out here huh  this is 37,000 miles of pristine  beautiful beach mate did you know that  Australia makes some of the finest wines  in the entire world  I didn't hear that  very much  wait hold up this isn't a movie no it's  tourism ad for Australia yes but listen  to you the best Crocodile Dundee since  Crocodile Dundee really yes really and  we had the best trip ever didn't we  it was pretty sweet  [Music]  heyyo there are some great flaunt deals  with trolley around there dude I get it  it's not a movie it's a commercial  you